2023 was a great year so now is a great
time to be looking ahead to a year
that's already looking very promising
with a lot of nice action anime starting
us on the horizon indeed it's my job to
brief you through 10 of what I think are
the most anticipated new action anime
this year showing you that even without
sequels in mind there are still a lot of
hot action series to look forward to
let's start our preview now then shall
we go go loser Ranger is starting things
off at number 10 oh my
with an English title that's an obvious
parody to a song that's made a lot of
childhoods any guesses as to what kind
of show we're looking at go- go loser
Ranger takes place in the aftermath of
an attempted Invasion by alien forces
after their defeat at the hands of the
Dragon Keepers the remnants of the
Invaders were forced into routine
humiliation being forced to reenact
their defeat in public one of the
monsters D decides that enough is enough
and sets off to defeat the Rangers by
infiltrating their ranks from within
turns out he's not the only one with
that plan in mind though a
deconstructive and alternative take on
the D sansu genre was not in my bingo
cards for things we'd be looking forward
to in 2024 but here we are I'm pretty
excited to see how this goes I'm going
to be pretty interested to see a
different perspective on the genre
through the lens of a monster henchman
and with supposed Heroes that may just
be as corrupt as the villains beneath
the
[Music]
surface next we take a look at unnamed
memory suffering a curse that causes
whichever wife he takes to Die the Crown
Prince Oscar climbs a tower in search of
answers said answers may just be on top
of the tower which provides a residence
for one of the strongest witches on the
continent after all thasha nicknamed The
Witch of the AZ your moon is said to
Grant the wishes of those who
successfully Brave The Perils of the
Tower and reach the top now things take
quite an interesting turn however when
Oscar sets his eyes on the witch why not
have dinha as his wife seeing as she's
strong enough to survive the curse that
way she can also put her expertise into
play and uncover the Mysteries behind
the spell put on the prince on the other
hand it becomes evident that there's
definitely a lot more surrounding This
Witch than her pretty face seems to
suggest Oscar gets embroiled in her past
and a lifetime of Dark Secrets unnamed
memory will be premiering in 2024
brought To Us by Studio Angi the team
doesn't have the most illustrious resume
as of now but they did give us some
shows I enjoyed I'm looking forward to
seeing how they deliver in this tale of
forbidden love magic and
fantasy an arch Demon's dilemma is our
number eight show for the coming
year for beings of such power there are
times when even Mages and Arch demons
face some very relatable problems the
mighty sorcerer zagan for one is what
you'd consider someone with awful social
skills many thanks to his years of
isolation due to an obsession with magic
but it's not like he's emotionless as it
is the emotion of love that pushes him
to purchase the slave of a dead Arch
demon the whair elf neilia now things
get pretty complicated for the socially
inept zagan who can't even express his
feelings nor confess his love for the
elf but together they look to overcome
life and the challenges of Love in This
fantasy romcom from the get-go Arch
Demon's dilemma gives us a setting that
may be quite polarizing with it shifting
between funny and surprisingly Bleak
with a premere year of 2024 we won't
have to wait too long to see how the jeo
relationship progresses in the crap sack
World they live
[Music]
in re monster comes in at number
seven now reincarnation stories are here
to stay and re monster looks to ride the
wave of momentum into the coming after
dying tomoki ganata finds himself
reincarnated in the fantasy world as a
goblin unfortunately goboro as he's
known is extremely weak he does have an
ace up his sleeve though or should I say
two actually the first is that he
retains memories of his previous life
and the second is how he can get
stronger and acquire new abilities
through eating now in this world where
the strong rule will we see the rise of
a new Champion fans of weak to strong
stories and overpowered characters will
have something to like and the intrigues
brought about by the story's perspective
and surprisingly dark aspects or to turn
some heads remonster comes to our
screens pretty early with having a
scheduled spring 2024
[Music]
release we have mechanical arms as our
next
title
alien life forms appeared on the planet
taking the form of sentient mechanized
Limbs and being dubbed Mecca oud our
protagonist Hikaru finds himself in an
involuntary partnership with a Mecca oud
that's laid dormant for a long time
armor to protect the duo the
organization arms assigns Hikaru an
observer another Mech user named Aki she
has her own mission and one thing leads
to another causing Hikaru and Aki to
become entangled with another
organization gami group that sees out
the mythical Mecha UD said to Grant
unlimited power now mechanical arms
isn't a new anime nor is it unique it
started as a standalone episode that
came as a result of a Kickstarter
project half a decade ago on another
note the premise already reminds me of
several anime I liked such as parasite
or while being given a Sci-Fi and Mecca
dressing despite not breaking a lot of
new ground mechanical arms in its
previous Incarnation does have the right
notes in parts that matter I'm looking
forward to seeing how it fares as a TV
[Music]
series 2024's already looking pretty
promising with these titles making their
debut but I'm not done talking about
them just yet we're only halfway through
and if you like what you've seen so far
then don't hesitate to hit that like
button and subscribe to the channel
proceeding with the next title on the
list we take a look at
windbreaker fuin high school a school
where the Strong Survive is filled with
degenerates who take pride in their
strength much that Pride isn't misplaced
as most students use their power to
protect their town but none of that
matches to Haruka Sakura Haruka has zero
interest in the heroic aspects of
becoming strong none of that whole sappy
being a hero or being a team player sort
of thing he aims for one thing and one
thing only to be the strongest there is
fighting his way to the top it seems
that Tokyo Revengers had quite a lasting
impact as I feel that this series was
very much inspired by it if we're going
to look at it on a surface level The
Source materials got great art and while
the show doesn't particularly stand out
in terms of originality it does remain
very entertaining it's a title that
relies a lot on the rule of cool and
with a world and character designs that
oo charisma I'd say the windbreaker
succeeds in that
regard Suicide Squad isaki is also
coming this
[Music]
[Applause]
2024 nobody really saw this coming back
in mid 2023 and I'm still quite
surprised that Suicide Squad became the
inspiration for an upcoming anime and an
isekai one at that it's got some big
time people back in it too with the
people behind rezero and Viv as well as
be zeab Manning the script it really
pequs my curiosity to see how Harley
Quinn and the team of Misfits will fare
in the world of swords and Magic anime
is where some of the most outlandish
ideas get the chance to rise and I
wonder what the team's cooking out for
us it feels very much like the 2016
movie in terms of premise but set in a
fantasy world still I'm bracing myself
for a lot of wild surprises the anime
can have in store the tale of these
super villains looking to conquer their
Fantasy Realm seems to be an Adventure
that you're not going to want to
miss let's open up the top three with
Mission yakura
[Music]
Family spy and Secret Agent shows have
been getting mixed levels of ESS the
past couple of years now haven't they
the latest one to join the team is
coming in 2024 the much awaited
adaptation of a shownin jump manga our
protagonist tho has quite a turbulent
life past traumas rendering him socially
distant from anyone but his childhood
friend and love interest mutsumi turns
out msum's Life Is Nothing But Ordinary
and she belongs to a family of super
spies featuring her overprotective
brother who wants nothing more but to
get rid of tho for the sake of her
safety this Burns tho to get out of the
situation by marrying mutsumi making
making him an official member of the
family thus begins his quest of becoming
a powerful spy getting to know his new
eccentric In-laws in the process and
diving into the family's Dark Secrets a
quirky manga with characters that show
good chemistry this is shaping up to be
a promising hit for 2024 it's really
enjoyable and it's got a lot of what
you'd typically be looking for in a
title like this fast-paced action
sequences a good amount of comedy and a
very likable cast for you to
enjoy
[Music]
guu number eight is up next and this
one's a
[Music]
banger guu have long been attacking
Japan in response an elite military unit
called the defense corpse are sent to
combat the clash between men and guu is
nothing short short of cataclysmic
filled with intense stories that will be
told for the rest of time GAA hibino
plays no part in that in fact he's
nothing more than a mere sweeper people
assigned to clean up guu remains once
the climactic battle's over not that
he's fond of his fate as he wants
nothing more than to be one of the brave
ones who kill guu for a living
everything changes when he encounters a
parasitic guu that forces itself into
him turning him into one of them finding
himself at the crossroads between
Mankind and guu gafar decides to put his
lifelong dream of hunting Kaiju into
action a protagonist who becomes part
monster to fight monsters now that seems
like a good Old Reliable formula for
Success if chainsaw man and parasite or
any indication guu number eight as a
manga started off really strong and a
very engaging read given that production
IG is leading the anime adaptation I've
got nothing but high expectations for
this one expect nothing short of amazing
battles suspenseful moments and gripping
[Music]
Cliffhangers
however the crown for the most
anticipated non-sequel action title for
2024 is
D hot-tempered Momo ayas believes that
ghosts and spirits are real meanwhile
the nerdy Ken takakura believes that
aliens and UFOs are real when a chance
encounter makes their path cross and
their beliefs Clash both set forth to
prove themselves right need to get more
than what they bargain for neither turns
out to be wrong and an alien abduction
and a spiritual possession later the two
start to bond over their encounters with
the supernatural but that's just the
beginning of the Absurd phenomena headed
their way aliens monsters and ghosts are
just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to the challenges the duo will
face in this Supernatural action series
if there's one description I can give
for Dandan is that it's a show that
thrives on the Absurd you know the
over-the-top shenanigans that can be
described as just Anime filled with
crazy moments and wild incidents
featuring the supernatural it's pretty
fun to follow and it really is a title
that thrives on the insanity being
filled with humor and a solid main cast
to carry the series for people who can
appreciate the unhinged comedy the only
anime can offer this is a must-watch for
2024 that's what I have for the most
anticipated new action anime of 2024
it's quite a good Library we're looking
at filled with action titles of varying
flavor I want to know what your favorite
one is though so please tell me in the
comment section thanks for watching and
I hope to see you soon stay cool stay
awesome